the white Mercedes was caught on a CCTV  camera in Hatton Garden on the first  night of the raid and a NPR automatic  number plate retrieval showed it was  used to get a key bit of equipment on  the second day of the raid police found  it parked outside John Collins's North  London home surveillance teams followed  him and the car they saw Collins and  Danny Jones together inside the vehicle  Jones they discovered had visited the  same DIY store at the same time as the  car had been driven there Collins and  Jones's phone records revealed  conversations with Terry Perkins before  the raid surveillance on those three men  showed them later having meetings with  Bryan Reader in a North London pub  police had connected the four  ringleaders